c'est un rituel devenu presque inutile
comme chaque semaine
marie continue d'entretenir
soigneusement ses chambres d'hôtes
mais faute de clients ces chambres
restent désespérément vides
d'habitude à cette période ci on a 80 %
d'occupation est là aujourd'hui nous
sommes à 0
c'est une perte qu'on ne récupérera pas
et ça nous met dans une réel danger
90 % de perte de chiffre d'affaires des
réservations annulées jusqu'en décembre
pour la propriétaire beaunoise la crise
sanitaire est lourde de conséquences
mais en tant qu'indépendante elle ne
bénéficiera pas des 3000 euros dette de
la région
une situation qu'elle vit comme une
injustice nous sommes assujettis à la
tva
nous payons notre urssaf et toutes nos
cotisations nous sommes simplement dans
une autre catégorie que nos confrères
hôteliers et notre statut d'indépendant
ne doit pas nous exclure c'est une
aberration
le 24 avril la région bourgogne franche
comté en effet mis en place une aide
d'urgence pour les hébergements de
tourisme
mais en regardant de plus près les
critères les entreprises individuelles
et auto-entrepreneurs ne font pas partie
des bénéficiaires
cette gérante installé dans l'yonne
parle de discrimination
on nous conseille la considère pas comme
des professionnels du tourisme
voilà on n'est pas inclus dans ce
groupement de professionnels voilà je
suis renseigné autour de moi nous sommes
nombreux à avoir pris les empreintes
assez lourd pour rénover ces maisons
comment allons-nous faire en septembre
lorsque nous devrons européenne aux
échéances les professionnels
indépendants ont lancé une pétition
de son côté la classe politique n'a pas
tardé à réagir
dans un courrier adressé à la présidente
de région françois sauvadet demande à
inclure les auto entrepreneurs dans les
bénéficiaires du fonds d'urgence
une demande qui pourrait être examinée
le 29 mai lors de la prochaine
commission permanente